yan monplaisir chef de file du groupe
ben payal chance à l'assemblée de
martinique et dans son crédit ce matin
bonjour yan monplaisir
bonjour maurice vient le temps bonjour à
tous les auditeurs hier soir serge
letchimy le président du parti
progressiste martiniquais n'a pas été
très tendre avec la coalition rassemblée
pour baby en chance à l'occasion des
voeux de son parti où ses jeux trinel
toutes les formations qui composent
cette coalition ont peur de nos peurs
d'alfred marie-jeanne personne n'ose
s'opposer à lui et il a dit également
que vous il ya de mon plaisir que vous
soutenez un dictateur qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça ce matin à serge chimie je
lui répondrai tout simplement qu' il
faut arrêter les excès de langage et la
violence dans dans les critiques
je sais que c'est une culture chez
certains personnellement je souhaite qu
on ait un débat démocratique serein et
donc voilà je commenterai pas plus vous
avez voulu de mots de moments des
changes c'était samedi dernier avec vos
sympathisants à la batelière on ya
appris pas mal de choses dans ni dernier
la première c'est que votre groupe au
sein du gras sans big baby h ans
deviendra une association politique le
22 février prochain pourquoi tout
simplement je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi nous avons notre groupe est né
de notre volonté d'être présents dans là
tant débat politique au moment des
élections de pour la collectivité
territoriale de martinique
nous ne sommes pas une association nous
ne sommes pas un parti politique nous
sommes cite le nom de la liste est donc
dans le cadre des réflexions du travail
que nous menons
il nous est apparu nécessaire de qu'il y
ait un espace plus organisé déjà pour
pouvoir éventuellement pour ceux qui le
souhaitent apporter un soutien notre
mouvement trouver un espace qui
juridiquement
s'ils répondent vous avez formaliser les
choses en vue des prochaines échéances
électorales
oui d'une certaine manière on nous nous
organisons
les choses pour répondre aux exigences
je dirais y compris certaines résidences
légal ouais parce que dans celle de bas
pays en chance il ya quand même des
personnes qui viennent d'horizons
différents vous veniez des républicains
vont mal et orbi venait vient de lui dit
je crois
d'autres personnes donnent d'ailleurs
pour sera-t-il alors cette association
ce sera un nouveau combo nonce de plus
non justement on veut pas faire un que
c'est pour ça que nous n'avons nous
avons imaginé que ça pouvait être un
parti politique de plus mais je ne le
souhaite pas nous ne souhaitons pas
l'idée non c'est simplement pour m
d'organisation après on vient d'horizons
différents c'est bien le sens de notre
démarche moi je souhaite qu'on arrive à
travailler ensemble qu'on rassemble et
si nous voulons rassembler il faut tout
le monde aujourd'hui tout le monde veut
travailler ensemble malheureusement tout
le monde heureusement avis sur bet tout
ça va dans le bon sens pas partie de
plus ce serait mieux
monsieur violons ça ne sera pas une
coalition de plus nous sommes au sein
d'une majorité nous sommes un groupe qui
a été élu sur des bases très clair nous
avons appelé les gens à voter pour nous
dans le cadre d'un rassemblement dans
nous étions précurseurs
mais moi je souhaite vraiment je
m'écoutais curseur retour à ce moment à
tout moment de la vie si vous voulez
constituer une force il faut bien
rassembler et donc voilà on est dans
l'air du temps mais derrière mon plaisir
si vous y pensez déjà à transformer bas
payant chance en association c'est parce
que quelque part peut-être pas
satisfaits de cette coalition que vous
avez monté certains décembre 2015 pas du
tout pas du tout je me trouve très bien
pendant qu'ils sont travaillants nous
travaillons pour la martinique je vous
explique que ce sont des choses
pratiques
il faut bien il faut bien qu'ils aient
une organisation pratique qui fonctionne
on a vu logo samedi dernier à la
batelière alors c'est un m a avec une
apostrophe il apostrophe c'était la
corde avec nous tout ce match c'est
l'angoissé le logo c'est le voeu de
l'association qui va qui va porter je
dirais les réflexions et qui va mettre
en oeuvre les moyens pour que nous
puissions organiser ont continué de
fonctionner dans le cadre de grands
débats que nous n'avons pas cessé de
mener depuis
depuis la période qui a précédé les
dernières élections ça veut dire quoi
emma vous deviendrez le 22 sept
pour l'instant nous voulons faire un peu
de teasing jour cachottier se battait
sur les ondes de la première
votre groupe de six élus il ya le mot
plaisir donc vos marinades torpille
diane montre aussi versailles soutane
car il mousse miguel laventure c'était
une bien belle image de famille samedi
dernier tout le monde semble aller dans
un même sens mais pourtant yan
monplaisir
autant j'ai pu ressentir comme un grain
de sable dans cette machine parce que
vous avez trop insister auprès de
milliane aventure après l'intervention
de ce dernier
on rappelle qu'il est conseil exécutif
en charge des affaires financières à
l'assemblée de martinique vous avez
insisté sur une aide de sa part trop
timide
concernant les finances oui je voulais
vous l'avez entendu nous nous attendons
le faisons quand même
non c'était pas pesant une île à miguel
a indiqué très clairement il a une tâche
qui n'est pas facile je le sais il a
indiqué très clairement que il était
dans le groupe et qu'il souhaitait
participer et apporter sa contribution
au groupe et où j'ai lu et je lui ai
simplement dit syrie j'ai voulu inviter
chiche j'ai pas dis chiche aider
simplement souligner le fait qu'il y
avait des projets en cours sur lesquels
d'ailleurs il ya déjà eu des décisions
arrêtées à la fois par l'exécutif par le
président de l'exécutif soumise à
l'assemblée voté par l'assemblée et que
maintenant on était dans la phase de
mise en oeuvre et que je comptais sur
lui et sur son engagement pour que ce
soit fait rapidement parce que ça tarde
trop il s'agit de projets jérémy en faut
en gros c'est un projet de fonds avec
l'union européenne pour aider les
petites et moyennes entreprises pourquoi
ça bloque dans un secteur quand même
assez vital pour l'économie
martiniquaise pourquoi ça ne va pas plus
vite que cela aurait dû aller plus vite
ce projet jérémy ça pourrait aller plus
vite mais je pense que ça ira plus vite
parce que je pense que miel aventure
aura compris que c'est un engagement de
notre groupe qui a été introduit par le
président de l'exécutif à la demande de
marines et de torpilles et que nous
souhaitons qu'il soit mis en oeuvre très
rapidement parce que les entrants 6
millions de nairas même ses 130 millions
d'euros
il ya beaucoup de petites entreprises
qui sont dans la tente et est ce que
j'ai voulu lui dit
c'est que maintenant il fallait passer
aux actes ouais oui parce qu'il ya un
autre projet qui concurrencent celui là
ils concurrencent pas il ya un autre
projet qui a déjà été votée mais qui est
un peu un fonds beaucoup plus petit qui
est un instrument qui est nécessaire
sans doute pour les microprojets qui est
sur un million d'euros et qui a une
autre convocation davantage poussé par
miguel laventure celui là oui qui a été
porté par milliers de l' aventure donc
il ya concurrence de projet vous
comprenons ces personnes qui sont à
l'extérieur qui vous écoutent ce matin
ils se disent mais les choses ne vont
pas si bien que ça dans ce pays et on ne
fait pas avancer des dispositifs qui
pourraient aider davantage les
entreprises vous entendez ça ce matin il
y avait mon plaisir je l'entends pas
comme ça ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est mon rôle c'est mon rôle je suis
animateur du débat c'est normal qu'on
m'entende je suis animateur d'un groupe
j'entends les uns et les autres et
marinette torpille m'a indiqué qu'elle
souhaitait que je souligne la nécessité
d'une d'une attention soutenue de miguel
laventure pour faire en sorte que ce
projet soit mise en oeuvre rapidement
je les fais et je les fais publiquement
parce que je souhaitais dans la
transparence que miguel entendre ce que
nous avons à lui dire de la rapidité
d'exécution de ce projet jérémy est ce
que c'est ce qu'ils pourraient en
découler une scission au sein de votre
groupe mais non on n'est pas moi mais je
suis pas dans l'esprit de scission je
suis juste que de rassembler ici les
choses qui se passent les messieurs pas
samedi matin samedi matin vous n'avez
rien entendu qui creuse et qui relèvent
d'une quelconque division qui vieillit
des débats internes qu'il y ait des
débats au sein de la majorité qu'il y
avait des débats au sein de notre groupe
c'est sain c'est normal bon à partir de
là est-ce qu'il faut systématiquement y
voir des ferments de divisions je ne le
crois pas m on vous croit sur parole
nyan au plaisir mais vous n'allez pas me
croire sur parole seulement vous allez
vous allez me croît sur les actes oui
allez voir la transcription de tout cela
dans les faits on regardera justement
dans les faits le grand débat national
d'un grand débat national nous avons
entendu tout à l'heure sur nos antennes
david zobda le maire du lamentin qui ira
à paris à l'elysée
et on entendu le maire du duc de ducos
qui dit que les solutions sont ici vous
pensez que il pourra sortir quelque
chose pour nous martiniquais vu toutes
nos expériences passées
le comité interministériel pour
l'outre-mer le moment le grand livre
bleu les assises entre ted réunion qui
aboutissent à de jolis livres de jolis
dossier puis et puis & prom 1re premier
élément de réponse il faut y aller il ne
faut jamais refuser le dialogue
premiers éléments de réponse deuxième
élément de réponse je ne crois pas qu'il
en sortira grand chose nous avons eu
parce que il faut malgré tout souligné à
aux autorités nationales les
problématiques de nos territoires
souligné les difficultés que rencontrent
les municipalités dans les outre-mer et
souligné la nécessité de tenir compte
des particularités de nos territoires
si on ne le fait pas qui le fera pour
nous maintenant vous me demandez est ce
que je suis je pense que ça va être la
panacée est ce qu'il y aura un miracle
non je n'y crois pas nous avons eu les
états généraux
nous avons eu le grand débat sur les sur
les outre mer on n'arrête pas de nous
consulter
on nous entend alors il en sort quelques
fois des petites choses ou des choses
importantes par exemple l'assemblée
unique
après le les états généraux a permis
l'adaptation pour chacun des territoires
du système qu'il souhaitait mais moi je
ne crois pas beaucoup à la solution
miracle je crois que je suis pas je suis
pas défaitiste
jeudi il faut y aller parce qu'il faut
dire il faut être entendu mais je ne
crois pas que nous aurons les réponses
qui grépon qui sont du niveau de ce que
nous sommes en droit d'attendre merci
beaucoup et yan monplaisir chef de file
de bas pays enchanté puis on viendra le
22 février pour savoir qui sera ainsi
autour de vous pour la présentation de
cette association politique mais merci
merci davance merci à tous ceux qui
viendront
[Musique]